this is now James Franco's fourth
collaboration with Sam Raimi
let's hope it's better than the last one
oz the great and the powerful is
directed by Sam Raimi it stars James
Franco michelle williams rachel weisz
mila kunis amongst other people as well
it's sort of a reimagining spin-off tale
sequels something or other of The Wizard
of Oz in this movie James Franco plays a
magician and he has big dreams for what
he wants to be he wants to be this great
man like Thomas Edison who invents
something or become something or in some
way inspires people and he eventually
gets whisked away in a hot-air balloon
off to us and in us they have this
prophecy where this one man a wizard
will come and bring balance to
everything he'll make everything safe
he'll keep everyone protected he'll use
his magic in his ways to keep everyone
happy and you'll be able to keep the bad
people away the evil witches and
creatures and what not and what James
Franco's character Oz discovers that if
he is in this position he will have many
riches and many beautiful women at his
disposal he decides hey you know what
maybe I'll let him think I am a wizard
for a while now I'm a fan of Sam Raimi
and I like his style he has a really in
your face kind of style sometimes but
all of his movies even the ones that
aren't as good as others they'll look
very good I mean he never has made a
bad-looking movie and he actually is
able to inject a fairly cool sense of
realism into really over-the-top moments
he has a way of doing that he puts
things on the screen like hands just
popping out and you know latching onto
tables and hands popping out of the dirt
and lots of hands popping out and making
creepy hand gestures some of these
really over-the-top moments I can drag
me to hell and the Evil Dead films
they're all big and larger-than-life but
he has a really good way of making him
feel grounded and I'm very pleased and
surprised to say that I actually had a
really good time with this movie I
really wasn't expecting much going into
this film even though I like Sam Raimi I
like James Franco and I like pretty much
all the talent involved with this movie
for some reason the trailers didn't
impress me and I just was not interested
in seeing this film I really find myself
enjoying it it does have some rocky
moments it has some problems but for the
most part I really enjoyed this film one
of the best things about this movie is
actually James Franco himself he gives a
really good performance here he's able
to pull off that I'm acting like I'm
this big guy even though I'm
I'm trying to keep it secret without it
coming off to cliched these you've seen
a lot of movies where characters pretend
they are something that they're not just
because they want to get ahead in life
or whatever but he does a good job with
it he's very funny in this movie he
sometimes pops like this humongous grin
it just makes you crack up you know and
it was cool to see his character mature
the evolution of his character as he
realized he had to step up and you know
be a man
Rachele vice is also very good in the
film as is Michelle Williams now Mila
Kunis is in this movie and she has a
pretty substantial role she starts out
as this character thats like has a crush
I'm James Franco and she goes other
places if you've seen any two posters
for this movie you can probably guess
but I'm not gonna spoil it for you in
case you don't know she was the weakest
edition in the cast in my opinion I
actually like Mila Kunis but for some
reason she didn't feel like she belongs
in this movie her performance just
wasn't as strong as everyone else's and
it felt as if she was reading lines and
where a character eventually turned into
what she turned into I thought it was
actually even worse most of the time the
visuals in the movie looked fantastic so
many beautiful colors so many great
sights and Sam Raimi has a really good
flow to this movie with this direction I
really like the way he shot this movie
he did a really nice job but then there
were a few moments where the visuals
were like wow that's a CGI effect right
there it does take some getting used to
when there's an entirely CGI monkey
there at all times eventually you get
used to it but at first it was kind of
like either talking to a CGI thing it's
not really it's not real now something I
also really liked about this movie was
the addition of this character this
china doll who is very fragile and could
easily break her character was so
adorable that is like the cutest
character I have seen in the movie in
such a long time like she honestly that
character broke my heart the story of
that character when you first meet her I
was literally just sitting there like
fix her do it I'm sorry
don't look at me don't look at me don't
look at the authority she was by far my
favorite supporting character and she
added something to the movie that I
wasn't expecting a really good sense of
childlike heart also the finale of the
movie I thought was great I didn't
expect it to go the way it did and I
thought that they handled it really well
and I was impressed with this movie
overall it does have issue
like the first 20 minutes of the movie
are entirely black-and-white with a full
screen like 4 by 3 format I like that it
was different and I dug it but then as
soon as it gets to Oz and the picture
expands for like the first like 20
minutes he was in Oz I wasn't really
feeling it it started to pick up once he
went on his adventure for like that
first 20 minutes in Oz it was a little
slow and that leads me to one of my
bigger problems in the movie it is not
perfectly paced at times it's a little
too long I feel like that could have cut
some scenes out but overall I had a
surprisingly fun time with us I actually
really enjoyed it and I'm going to give
it a B thanks a lot for watching guys
and as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes